qué función crece a medida que x
creencias infinito o sea la función
tiene que hacerse más grande mientras x
se hace más grande y también crece a
medida que x decrece hacia menos
infinito o sea que la función también
tiene que crecer conforme x se hace cada
vez más pequeña y vamos a pensar en esas
dos condiciones veamos aquí ya tengo a
mis funciones así que cuál de ellas
satisface la primera condición que
crezca a medida que x crece es infinito
entonces nos estamos moviendo hacia el
infinito nos estamos moviendo hacia la
derecha y queremos ver qué hacen las
funciones veamos efe x que es la primera
si x se mueve hacia la derecha entonces
la función como pueden ver en la gráfica
la función se hace cada vez más pequeña
no está creciendo así que fx no
satisface la primera condición que hay
de hd x o bueno vamos en orden de x que
x a medida que x crece a medida que aquí
se va hacia el infinito se mueve hacia
la derecha gx también parece que está
creciendo así que quede x satisface la
primera condición y hdx pues mientras x
se hace cada vez más grande hdx también
parece hacerse cada vez más grande así
que hdx también satisface la primera
condición
vamos con la segunda ya no tenemos que
checar a efe x porque fx no cumple la
primera condición así que vamos
directamente con dx tiene que crecer a
medida que x decrece hacia menos
infinito entonces ahora nos movemos
hacia la izquierda y cuando nos movemos
hacia la izquierda gdx si parece estar
creciendo si la gráfica si está
creciendo la gráfica cada vez cada vez o
para cada valor de x
gx toma valores cada vez más grandes
mientras avanzamos o en cierto sentido
retrocedemos hacia menos infinito
entonces que x si cumplen la segunda
condición y hd x pues hdx mientras más
nos vamos hacia menos infinito la
función se hace cada vez más más pequeña
toma valores negativos cada vez más
pequeños menos 8 menos 9 así que está
decreciendo por lo tanto hdx no cumple
la segunda condición de modo que la
única función que satisfacen las dos
condiciones es gx y yo diría que quede x
es la respuesta correcta